meet bad bunny the Puerto Rican rapper
taking over YouTube bad bunny is a trap
rapper who is making waves in the Latin
music world
his debut album sample to sample scored
the number-one spot on the top Latin
Albums Chart this year but it's probably
not the first time you've seen him he's
worked with cardi B on I like it and Mia
with Drake and he just dropped his new
song kya but bad bunnies appeal extends
beyond the star-studded music
collaborations he's been instrumental in
bringing Latin trap to mainstream
American audiences while rapping mostly
in Spanish bad bunny originally posted
his music on SoundCloud independently
but was quickly noticed and signed on to
a record label since then he's been a
consistent heavy hitter on the Hot Latin
Songs chart with 46 tracks and 7 on the
Hot 100
along with his own singles he's teamed
up with other Hispanic and Latino top
artists to create billboard hits such as
sensual Avadh with J Balvin and Prince
Royce and a remix of a buffet with Ozuna
and Nicky Jam in 2018 he collaborated
with cardi B and J Balvin for I like it
making it bad bunny's first number-one
single on the US Billboard it was
followed with another collaboration with
Drake for Mia and Jennifer Lopez fourth
eggless a garnering him even more fans
in the US and around the world this
leads up to his debut albums tiempo de
siempre which unsurprisingly skyrocketed
to the number-one spot on the top Latin
Albums Chart with his rhythmic cadence
and slow slurs bad bunny has a unique
sound that is unlike anything else on
the Latin music scene this is largely
due to his willingness to cross music
genres ranging from Latin trap but I got
thrown and pop in an interview with
billboard he credits his unique music
style to his parents and home country of
Puerto Rico when he was little he
listened to salsa merengue and pop
ballads at the same time he was singing
to reggaeton the hip hop bad bunnies
rise to fame isn't only attributed to
his music but to his unshakable sense of
self he has a distinct style with his
painted nails and bright patterns which
have made him a fashion inspiration and
you're likely to spot him with a pair of
trendy shades in a music culture that
often Chan
ian's traditional masculinity bad bunny
is a breath of fresh air that redefines
gendered norms and societal expectations
through his music and clothing choices
he preaches messages of south love and
respect for others in the music video
for Caudill there are several gender
bending moments and even a scene
featuring an inclusive fashion show with
models of varying ages abilities races
and sizes in another music video for
solo than me he tackles the issues of
domestic violence against women with
just three years in the music industry
under his belt bad bunny has become one
of the most recognizable faces of Latin
trap while also helping bring Latin
music to the mainstream in 2018 bad
bunny was YouTube's third most viewed
artist with 7 billion views now bad
bunny is headlining his own
international tour and selling out
venues across the world he sold out his
homecoming concerts in Puerto Rico
within hours which led to adding a third
day in addition J Balvin has teased an
upcoming collaborative album whatever
the next album may be we can't wait to
see more from Bad bunny
[Music]